so this is dr. Berg and we're going to
do a little video on debugging weight
loss we have Connie with us and I want
to kind of go through kind of your
history when you were I guess in high
school what did you weigh about 115 for
number of years
it's like petite so here you are going
along and then when did you start
noticing that you started to gain some
weight well I had two children and then
a relationship with my husband who was
psychotic yeah um started to just push a
lot of stress and just trying to survive
day to day became stuck on survive yeah
you were actually in flat a fight
because we did a little test and it your
body is in flight-or-fight that's that
adrenal stress and so what what age did
you notice that the weight started when
you started gaining weight well when you
live with someone that has emotional
disorders when you're in a safety net of
family there's a feeling of security at
about 34 we've been married
number of years and the children started
to get older and we moved away from that
safety net of my father's presence and
it just became very crazy at that time
with a lot more happening and it just
wasn't ever a relaxed setting
it was always pins and needles you never
knew how that person was going to react
to anything you did it was like jump
through this hoop and you know one
hurdle after another but the hurdles
always got moved out a little further
yeah until you were the one that was led
to believe you were the nut right yeah
that make you feel like you're crazy
then you so you had this marriage that
was um not great actually it was it was
terrible so you had that and then you
had I think it was like within a matter
of was it a year that you
nineteen loss of people that you lost
yes many people started just exiting
aunts uncles grandparents and it was
just an incredible number of people that
left this world very quickly and very
rapid succession and after my husband's
passing he committed suicide I moved to
Ohio to just get out of Dodge I couldn't
be around those surroundings any longer
I had two children there in Michigan but
I needed to leave and in my leaving and
coming to Ohio to work there was just
more stress and more changes and my body
just wasn't able to cope anymore and
more and more weight every year just
continued to pile on and then health
issues started to crop up with well
diagnosis of post-traumatic stress
disorder which was just from all of the
traumas of my past and living with this
man and then female issues going forth
with you know looking at either having
hormone replacement therapy or
antidepressants because of the
depression and the mood swings and the
anxiety and it was just you know they
wanted to give me one drug after another
and I just kept backing away from it
because I don't believe in that type of
process that's not for me I wanted to do
it naturally but naturally I I went out
and walked every day and I could try to
eat right and nothing was making the
sympathetic system work with me it was
working against me at every turn
yeah you told me about that because what
happened is that you you tried pretty
much everything on the planet and then
low-calorie diets you know who Keller
does yeah I know it's like well they say
that you know just eat less and exercise
more you'll be fine
so you eventually got to a point where
you're just kind of stuck and I think
somehow you kind of stumbled on some of
the videos that I had and then
that you you're watching those for a
while then you quote you came out from
Ohio and you're here for like a week so
what we found was we you're in flight a
fight so we began to do acupressure
which is a stress extraction technique
and tell me kind of what you're feeling
as we're doing this well um I kind of
felt like I was and one of those those
air filled jumping bouncy type things or
that I was kind of like zipped into one
of these sumo wrestler suits and I was
just kind of bouncing off the world I
think I mentioned to you the other day
that no one would go to a sports event
with me because if you sat in the
bleachers with me I was jiggling all the
time I was on constant move constant
just stress movement yeah um my bridge
even even at night I would wake up and
find myself rocking and and moving
because I just didn't feel good in my
skin it was not a nice place to be
and after the first day here it was like
being unzipped out of that and someone
taking me out of that bouncy just my
body feels relaxed like it hasn't felt
in years
um it's I know the trauma is still there
and I've worked through the traumas but
now I feel like I'm I'm free it's it's
my body is responded now along with
being stuck that's great because the
physical body is like a sponge and it
holds on the stress and so everyone's
focus on I'll change your diet change
your diet exercise more but on top of a
body that is a stress bucket it doesn't
work so basically it's a very common
story where you have a stress trigger
that is needs to be removed so so if
anyone's trying to lose weight and
you're going along and then all of a
sudden you start gaining weight and it's
not
coming off there's always a something
that occurs just before that in your
situation it was living with a
psychopath and you had 19 losses in a
very short period of time that's a
tremendous shock to your system so how
can the hormones work it shuts
everything down so you can be on the
diet forever so I've had people go on a
vacation
removing the out of the environment from
all these people and eat poorly and lose
the time awake so we know the stress
will just tear you down so I think
that's great
Connie so I'm so so glad that you got
out here but now we now you can start to
heal you know and you're going to be
able to sleep in
well the techniques that you use here
are phenomenal to very quickly allow
that sympathetic nervous system to let
go it's amazing I was I'm still in awe
because I've done massages and saunas
and
anything that I could do to relax the
body but until this this has been just
amazing that's great well thank you very
much you're welcome thank you